school starts in just two weeks and
families across the valley are getting
ready we here at channel 8 are also
gearing up with our great school supply
drive we've partnered with smiths and
las vegas honda dealers to collect
school supplies through thursday john
langler joins us live at smith sky
canyon with more hi john
hi vanessa good afternoon to you we are
here inside the smith sky cannon here
are the donations that have already come
in you can see there's a couple there's
a backpack here we've got crayola
crayons note cards notebooks everything
you could possibly this is a pretty full
box i might have to get another one here
because we're going to be here until the
28th later this week is when our school
supply drive ends as you mentioned
vanessa it's really important to help
students before the new school year
which is only a couple of weeks from
today
get what they need so they are ready to
go when class starts on august 8th so
come here any smiths around the valley
you can donate to also las vegas honda
dealerships taking part in this and you
can try and fill these boxes all around
the valley as much as possible get kids
what they need we understand the
marching band is on break right now so
it's just me out here right now but if
you come here to the sky canyon meet me
drop off some school products and goods
to get the kids ready to go for the
school year we'll be back a little bit
later on in the program talk to the good
people here at smith's about what
they're doing but for now vanessa we'll
throw it back to you